اولا كيف تفسر قدره اسرائيل على تصفيه
خمسه من كبار القياديين الايرانيين في
العاصمه
السوريه من الواضح تماما بان اسرائيل
منخرط في حمله استفزازات قصوى وهذه الحمله
تهدف الى دفع ايران لارتكاب خطا او اخطاء
يمكن ان يبرر توسيع نطاق الحرب في غز او
يضع الولايات المتحده في مواجهه عسكريه
مباشره مع
ايران اذا هذه تعتبر انتصارا على كلا
الحالتين بالنسبه لاسرائيل يمكن ان ترد
ايران بشكل يحقق لاسرائيل اهدافها او لا
ترد ما يجعل
اسرائيل تعمل على اضعاف ايران من خلال عدم
ردها نعم هي سلسله اغتيالات بداتها
اسرائيل ربما تعود الى
2015 وفي كل مره
يتوعد الجانب الايراني بالرد وبحقه في ذلك
هل شهدنا ردا حقيقيا من ايران حتى الان
وهل نتوقع هذه
المره الى الان لم نرى الا افعالا رمزيه
من قبل ايران الاسبوع الماضي كان هنالك
هجوما استهدف منطقه اقليم
كردستان ردا
على او استهدف مركز التجسس اسرائيل ولكن
ليس على ذات المستوى يضاهي العمليات التي
قامت بها اسرائيل وهذه العمليات واغتيال
الصارخه لكن ايران لم ترد بشكل مكافئ
لماذا وهذا مرده الى ان القياده الايرانيه
لا تريد ان تقع في شرك ايران والذي يمكن
ان يؤدي الى تصعيد الصراع
ولكن هذه لعبه خطره للغايه لان هنالك
حدودا لضبط النفس من قبل ايران و توقيه
الحذر في رد فعلها وكذلك هذا يمكن ان يشمل
مناطق جغرافيه اوسع تقوم بها اطراف او
ميليشيات مدعومه من ايران وهوي من الفصائل
والميليشيات من غير الدول
والتي هي تعد عدوه لاسرائيل وهذا قد يكود
الى اس
حسابات في المنطقه يجعل هذا الصراع يخرج
من عقاله ويشمل المنطقه
برمتها كيف ترى او اين ترجح ان يكون الرد
الايراني على اسرائيل وباي صيغه من واقع
متابعتك بحيث تضمن
لايران الخروج باقل قدر من الخسائر
هنا
في الماضي راينا ان ايران او حلفاء ايران
اتخذوا قاموا بعمليات ضد ليس اسرائيل
بالضروره
ولكن فاليوم كان هنالك هجوما تذكر ان كان
هنك هجوما على قاعده عين الاسد في العراق
سقط في ضحيه امريكيه ولكن في كل حاله او
في كل مره كانت الولايات المتحده ترد
بالمثل وقام
باستهداف ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي في العراق
وهذه الحلقه العنف ستستمر وتتصاعد الى ان
تخرج من عقالها كما ذكرت نحن نعرف ان
الاسباب الجذريه لهذا الصراع وهذا النزاع
هو الحرب في
غزه وراينا مستوى خطر كبير يشهده العالم
وهذا قد يصبح اكثر توترا واكثر سخونه
ويمكن ان يفضي او يؤدي الى نتائ كارثيه
بالنسبه للجميع